good morning everybody welcome to
another Wednesday granted teacher in a
live stream number 28 I have a special
guest with me today special is not
especially i guess of course your
special guest this is Nina she might
look familiar guys this woman here uh we
do this every week day we share three
things were great before you guys in a
live chat know the drill there for those
of you watching out the words leave it
in the comments don't be don't be the
lurker don't be the person who just
watch his stuff take some action we
share it daily because it's important
because your attitude is an important
thing to do everyday like brushing your
teeth but for your mind I like that like
breastfeed mine like brushing teeth are
you ready look at the Thomas we're not
getting to the comments yet it's growing
up on the comments Lena's hey pay
attention this message that's coming up
um and then you feel it that you think
about why it's important to you I'm not
just listing things off you want the
benefits of the gratitude practiced and
you have to you have to feel it here
it's got to touch you so we're going to
do our three then we get to live chat
and talk about your three first up at
the top three yeah three things you get
one no I thought just when now that was
when we did with Hayden three things are
good oh ok that's ok no um three things
look at the three things my mom she
cares about me a lot every time she well
she call me almost like everyday to ask
me if I want this and that and she will
get it ready for me yeah my mom and then
uh second things I'm grateful for you
yeah you're very supportive always there
to help me yeah and then three grateful
for work my manager he's very
understandable would never talk to him
he understands and then yeah not gonna
get into very eco okay you talk
alright I will say that I most
ungrateful number one for Nina for
joining us here in the live stream I
think it's awesome that she put me as
her number two and I put her as my
number one no you put me as a number 3
i'm just saying I'm just saying Deena
it's just important number to a Y niñas
very supportive and and she and I'm be
but she's home this much she has some
other stuff to do later on I don't stick
stick around for the whole thing but she
had the few minutes to pop in and say hi
to you guys so I'm people to not do this
by myself every day um to Blue Jays one
last night good before my Blue Jays the
Hat stays on for now it's going to be a
tough climb back out where three two one
down but it's better than being
forwarded nothing down and going home so
I'm more than anything like the vibe of
the city and the excitement that
everybody's kind of feeling for the Blue
Jays it's fine it's good the city love
is good and number 3 i'm still getting
for my beard guys it's good here it's
still here i thought i was coming out
yesterday but I get one more day of a
beard Lee goodness Salinas not a fan but
I'm gonna join it maybe the thumbnail
will be this we'll see what happens
that's it those are three you can need
to go you can go let's see we got junior
I start this off what do you get before
I love it Jay rises grip before Edward
or Edward or is my website hosting guy
who does a lot of work helping us
anything website related on the host
inside so he's been amazing so he's
going for Edward or for providing
rock-solid for providing rock-solid for
Evans website ok for responsive adaptive
physiology in mirek mirek you'll
miraculous a round human bodies for
opportunities to help people rise all
layers of their life I love it cold last
morning welcome back Colt sue med hello
everyone thankful for God sky's the
limit great rising every
great rising everyone look at that what
a way to introduce yourself great rise
in everyone I love it sky's the limit
okay see how schools like that's crazy
every time we should cut couple of
everyone Melissa hello good morning
beautiful people I love it uh Jay rise
Nina all caps I love it rishi kappa nina
cement who is she oh man Melissa I'm
good for my friend july the friend in
july that's a cool name friend july who
returned from haiti last week cool Cal
CR 09 hello from Costa Rica hello Cal
income computer services greetings from
Macedonia I love it EMA is that at I IL
IC hello from Bologna Italy ciao Emma
Skye Sullivan I'm grateful for this
experience called life and everything in
it I love that did I tried to read Oh
deepanshu greetings from Singapore
welcome aboard J reyez heart heart for
Nina's mouth what I missed one I didn't
is fun oh wow i missed a whole bunch ok
let's go back up i miss the whole bunch
atlanta music DJ calm the best couple on
youtube I with the best clip on YouTube
yeah best is a relative term we're happy
that we're a happy couple on YouTube
jasmine I'm grateful for my ability to
help others I'm grateful for the pieces
of my story that society I'm able for
the pieces of my story that society okay
Jason we look for patients unusual
people and daily exercise grateful for
unusual people yeah you sure it is
different let's get compliments it's
true I am different I like being unusual
I'm fine with that Jasmine I'm grateful
for my ability to love unconditionally I
love that Melissa I'm grateful for Crest
toothpaste with scope
I love it I love what comes out crest
toothpaste with scope keeps my mouth
clean and fresh how's my husband Bob hey
you gotta get some Crest toothpaste the
scope friends okay okay is Sarah good
morning I'm grateful that I got better
after the cold I had over the weekend
ungrateful for fall season and I'm
grateful for today feeling better I hate
being sick to cement grateful for my
health me too I'm also healthy a lot
because Nina keeps me healthy she made
me my vitamin water for today and
brought in my lentils with egg that I
need to eat today so Nina's keep me
healthy Evan you're blushing today am i
blushing really can't tell you I just
trying to match Tina shirt you know much
Oh Nina is there nice hat thank you
happy will whens everyone best you pro
what else we got sky's the limit 09 I'm
grateful for my family in my life
teachers I love that J reyez loves a
beard I feel you man I agree a hundred
percent Lindsey first time love the
beard yeah that's what's up friends that
is what's up lindsey is grateful for my
beard grateful for your beard i love
that i am getting for my beer too this
is this is all fantastic stuff guys i
love it ah best q pro grateful for life
and for sunshine beautiful for
remarkable partners and for you Evan I
appreciate that thank you best you pro
Melissa I'm grateful for selling four
thousand pieces of clay women
accessories I don't know what clay women
or claim women accessories are but I'm
that's awesome congratulations Cal CR 09
hello from Costa Rica grateful for
realizing that in any situation there is
a gem of wisdom I love that breathe
fitness TV hey hey everyone left Laborde
Kimberly great morning great morning I
love that I'm grateful yeah you see with
your grateful should be a great morning
right great great even great full it's
full of great
full of greatness you're reading instead
of potential our message greatness okay
a grateful for my family we have a lot
of love in our house I'm grateful for my
job and my tips and good look for my
health I love it guys nine ten Nina has
to go we're going to hop on a twitch do
some business QA with Rishi cap TV and
Jay rise as we do a game of league of
legends i'm off to film video today i
was i didn't see his grave before video
day I'm so good before video days
wednesday i'm so pumped anyway guys have
an amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and i'll see
you soon